that is great Davies this is um a 63
year old a long-serving labor MP for
Swansea who has been accused by uh five
women police administratively suspended
from the party were being told in my
eras were chatting to Penning the
investigation to go on I see yes this MP
has been accused by the police code
website of making unwanted sexual
advances to five young women some
troubling stories that they've given
that website now Mr Davies has given a
statement to Politico saying I don't
recognize the allegations suggested and
I don't know who made them and he points
out that none of them have lodged a
formal complaint although he apologizes
for inadvertently he says causing
offense to anyone that's a statement he
gave the website we are now naming Mr
Davies he's been an MP since 1997. the
labor party have now suspended him
pending that investigation and we've had
a lot over the last few months and
longer about so-called pestminster
drinking culture in Parliament and there
is a lot of Spotlight on how political
parties are handling these sorts of
allegations